[Música]
las campanas suenan en el ayuntamiento
de sídney 96 veces cada uno por un año
de la vida de la reina isabel segunda
mientras los australianos se despertaban
con la noticia de la muerte de la
monarca británica más longeva
creo que significó mucho para muchas
generaciones de mujeres es una figura
increíble y ella quiero decir mientras
en el lapso de la historia que vivió es
bastante increíble
nadie puede sustituirla por supuesto
creo que la conexión con la gente es el
legado más importante que ha dejado la
que será james ver al otro lado del
pacífico la bandera canadiense se baja
media asta mientras los residentes de
todo el estado de la commonwealth
comienzan a marcar el fin de una era es
como he dicho al final de una era
cualquiera que sea la nueva era será
interesante ver si es tan popular como
en el pasado o si eso significa que el
apoyo puede morir un poco o tal vez la
monarquía cambiará en cierta forma si es
en jamaica la gente planteó dudas sobre
el futuro del rey carlos tercero como
monarca hui
y veremos en los próximos años pero no
esperamos que tenga el mismo tipo de
amor que tuvo la reina y ciertamente nos
hemos alejado de la energía popular en
torno a los miembros de la familia real
y hacia la princesa diana o megan market
ya sabes realmente una era diferente en
la que nos estamos moviendo
como aquellos en bahamas que no están
seguros de que el nuevo rey pueda estar
a la altura del legado de su madre
fernández work
ella ha hecho un tremendo trabajo y no
creo que carlos pueda llevarnos a
ninguna parte y creo que es su fin
para pérez de andrés
jamaica ha señalado que pronto podría
seguir a barbados en abandonar el reino
ya que el legado de isabel y el nuevo
papel del rey están en punto de mira